cyberdelics the idea that there's a
connection a relationship between
psychedelics and
cybernetics even though psychedelics are
more associated with spiritual
experiences and Transcendence of the
self and cybernetics is associated with
computers or technological Hardware the
truth is that psychedelics and
cybernetics are intimately
intertwined in fact there was an article
once that called Google the first
psychedelically informed
superpower so from where does this idea
originate that where what is the what is
the origin story right for the the
scenes of of the intersection of
psychedelics and cybernetics well for
this you have to go back to the 1960s in
Silicon Valley you know the bay area
near San Francisco we were in the middle
of the Psychedelic Revolution everybody
was was tuning in turning on dropping
out the whole thing was happening people
were obliterating their limiting beliefs
and their sense of self you know I think
Timothy Le said you experience a fresh
the hardly bearable Ecstasy of Direct
Energy exploding on your nerve endings
but what happens is that when
engineers and other technologists and
material thinkers and mathematicians had
these ecstatic experiences their
interpretive Frameworks were more
technical rather than seeing the grade
Beyond some evidence of a spiritual
realm they realize we already live in a
world that's infinitely mysterious where
forces are at play that we cannot see we
cannot touch we cannot smell and we
cannot see right and so from then they
realize if we can free our minds from
our limiting beliefs maybe we can free
ourselves through our technical
Proficiency in similar ways to the
degree that now our ideas can be
recorded in silica the contents of our
minds can be exteriorized our tools and
Technologies are engineering Miracles
right they are they are the a reflection
of what Terence McKenna called the coral
reef like animal right the human being
has become the extruder of technological
material can you get any more
psychedelic than that we take in matter
of low organization it goes through the
filters of the human mind then we
extrude space shuttles and iPhones we
engender complexity we rework materials
so that a hunk of junk becomes an iPhone
a device made of plastic and metal that
can communicate us with Minds across the
planet we can bring a musical sound ape
you know a perfect song to frame a
moment that seems to be showered by the
sky we can summon the song we can direct
it into being like a dream we can craft
our waking dreams and mediate our own
realities we have uploaded ourselves
into a matrix only to reveal that we
already live in a matrix that can be
programmed through our technical
proficiency and the digital Revolution
and the virtual Revolution is spilling
over into the biotechnological
revolution and then we're going to be
patterning biology which is also
software right which is also a
subversively psychedelic idea that all
is programmable and everything can be
upgraded and everything can be retuned
and everything can be transformed and
then nanotechnology which sees the
material world as programmable atoms
another psychedelic idea so when Li said
you experience a fresh the hardly
bearable Ecstasy of Direct Energy
exploding on your nerve endings that has
been made manifest by digital technology
virtual metaverses biotechnological mRNA
vaccines and eventually nanotechnology
creating buildings that self assemble we
are living in a magical world and if you
could timelapse human progress it would
look like our minds our consciousnesses
the imagination is spilling out of us
and we are actualizing the human
imagination we are designing the world
and ourselves into being right we we are
literally a thinking stratum of the
earth that is willing itself into
existence but that's already what what
biology is so it's biology becoming
aware of itself which is also a
psychedelic Insight when Tim dudy said
that psychedelic experiences
recontextualizes the self and makes us
realize we are a marvelous conduit in a
Timeless hole from which molecules and
meanings flow from neurons to nebula and
back again in ones and zeros in DNA code
and in programmable atoms my friends and
that's what makes the technological
Revolution and Singularity we're living
through psychedelic it is psychedelic
cyber delics is where psychedelics and
cybernetics meet that's the cyberdelic
revolution in the world we live in
[Music]
today